Soy un vicario de la Iglesia de Inglaterra.
He sido un sacerdote de la iglesia por 20 años.
La mayor parte de ese tiempo, he estado trabajando y luchando
con preguntas sobre la naturaleza de Dios. ¿Quién es Dios?
Y soy muy consciente que cuando dices la palabra Dios,
muchos dejan de prestar atención inmediatamente.
Y la mayoría, tanto dentro como fuera de la iglesia organizada,
todavía tienen la imagen de un controlador celestial,
un hacedor de reglas, un policía en el cielo que ordena todo,
y hace que todo pase.
Él protegerá a su propio pueblo,
y responderá las plegarias de los fieles.
En el culto de mi iglesia,
el adjetivo más frecuentemente usado acerca de dios es "todopoderoso".
Pero tengo un problema con eso.
Me he vuelto más y más incómodo
con esta percepción de Dios al pasar los años.
¿Realmente creemos que Dios es tipo jefe masculino que hemos estado presentando
en el culto y las liturgias todos estos años?
Claro, han habido pensadores
que sugirieron distintas maneras de ver a Dios.
Explorando lo femenino, el lado maternal de la divinidad.
Sugiriendo que el, o ella, se expresa a través de la falta de poder,
en vez del el poder.
Aceptando que Dios es desconocido e incognoscible por definición.
Encontrando profundas resonancias con otras religiones y filosofías
y en formas de ver la vida como parte de lo que es una búsqueda universal y global de sentido.
Estas ideas son populares en círculos académicos liberales,
pero la gente del clero como yo, ha estado reacia a darles cabida,
por miedo a crear tensión y división en las comunidades de la iglesia
por miedo a ofender la fe simple de los creyentes más tradicionales.
Yo e elegido no causar disturbios.
Luego, el 26 de diciembre del año pasado, hace solamente dos meses,
un terremoto submarino generó el tsunami.
Y dos semanas después, el domingo en la mañana del nueve de enero,
me encontré parado en frente de mi congregación --
cristianos inteligentes, bien intencionados, pensantes, la mayoría --
y tenía que expresar, de su parte, sus sentimientos y preguntas.
Yo tenía mis propias respuestas personales, pero también tenía un rol público,
y algo tenía que ser dicho.
Y esto es lo que dije.
Poco después del tsunami lei en el diario un artículo
escrito por el Arzobispo de Canterbury -- buen título --
sobre la tragedia en el sur de Asia.
La esencia de lo que decía ahi fue esto:
la mayoría de los afectados por la devastación y pérdidas de vida
no quieren teorías intelectuales sobre por qué Dios permitió que esto pasara.
Escribió, "Si algún genio religioso viene con una explicación
de como hacer sentido a todas estas muertes,
¿nos sentiríamos más felices, o más seguros, o más confiados en Dios?"
Si el hombre de la fotografía que apareció en los diarios,
sosteniendo la mano de su hijo muerto estuviera parado en frente nuestro ahora,
no habría palabras que pudieramos decirle.
Una respuesta verbal no sería apropiada.
La única respuesta apropiada sería un silencio compasivo
y algún tipo de ayuda práctica.
No es tiempo para explicaciones, prédicas, o teología;
es tiempo de lágrimas.
Esto es verdad. Aún así aquí estamos nosotros, mi iglesia en Oxford,
semi-despegados de los evento que pasaron en un lugar alejado,
pero con la fe golpeada.
Y queremos una explicación de Dios.
Demandamos una explicación de Dios.
Algunos han concluido que sólo podemos creer en un Dios que comparte nuestro Dolor.
De algún modo, Dios debe sentir nuestra angustia, nuestra pena,
y el dolor físico que sentimos.
De alguna manera el Dios eterno debe poder entrar en nuestras almas de seres humanos
y experimentar el tormento interno.
Y si esto es verdad, también debe ser que Dios conozca la dicha y la exaltación
del espíritu humano, también.
Queremos un Dios que pueda llorar con aquellos que lloran,
y se regocije con aquellos que se regocijan.
Esto a mi me parece, en dos formas a la ves, profundamente conmovedora y una declaración convincente
de la creencia cristiana acerca de Dios.
Por cientos de años, la ortodoxia prevaleciente, la verdad aceptada
era que Dios el Padre, el Creador, es inmutable
y entonces por definición no puede sentir pena o tristeza.
Ahora el Dios inmutable se siente un poco frio e indiferente para mi gusto.
Y los eventos devastadores del siglo 20
ha hecho que la gente se cuestione el Dios frío e insensible.
La masacre de millones en las trincheras y en los campos de concentración
ha hecho que la gente se pregunte, ¿dónde esta Dios con todo esto?
¿Quién es Dios en todo esto?
Y la respuesta fue, "Dios está en esto con nosotros,
o Dios no merece más nuestra lealtad"
Si Dios es un testigo, que observa pero que no se involucra,
entonces Dios puede muy bien existir, pero no queremos saber sobre él.
Muchos judíos y cristianos ahora se sienten así, lo sé.
Estoy entre ellos.
Entonces tenemos un Dios que sufre.
Un Dios que está intimamente conectado a este mundo, y a toda alma viviente.
Yo me identifico a esta idea de Dios.
Pero no es suficiente. Necesito hacer más preguntas,
y espero que sean las preguntas que también quisieran preguntar,
algunos de ustedes.
Las semanas pasadas me llamó la atención la cantidad de veces
que las palabras de nuestro culto se sintieron un poco inapropiadas, desubicadas.
Tenemos un servicio los martes a la mañana para monjas y sus chicos en prescolar.
Y la semana pasada cantamos con los chicos una de sus canciones favoritas,
"El hombre sabio construyó su casa sobre las rocas".
Quizás algunos de ustedes la conocen. Algunas de las palabras son:
"El hombre tonto construyó su casa sobre la arena /
y las inundaciones subieron / y la casa en la arena se destruyó".
Luego en la misma semana, en un funeral,
cantamos un himno familiar "aramos los campos y nos dispersamos"
un himno inglés muy popular.
En el segundo verso viene una línea "El viento y las olas le obedecen".
¿Lo hacen? No siento que podamos cantar esa canción otra vez en la iglesia,
luego de lo sucedido.
Entonces la primera gran pregunta es acerca del control.
¿Tiene Dios un plan para cada uno de nosotros? ¿Esta Dios en control?
¿Dios ordena cada momento? ¿Le obedecen el viento y las olas?
De tiempo en tiempo,
uno escucha a los cristianos contar la historia de cómo Dios organiza las cosas para ellos,
parar que todo termine saliendo bien.
Alguna dificultad superada, alguna enfermedad curada, algún problema evitado,
un lugar para estacionar encontrado en un momento crucial.
Puedo recordar a alguien diciendome esto,
con sus ojos brillantes y llenos de entusiasmo ante esta grandiosa confirmación de su fe
y la bondad de Dios.
Pero si Dios puede y va a hacer estas cosas --
intervenir para cambiar el flujo de los eventos --
entonces seguramente el pudo haber detenido el tsunami.
¿Tenemos una versión de Dios local que puede hacer pequeñas cosas como lugares para estacionar,
pero no cosas grandes como olas de 500 millas por hora?
Eso no es aceptable como cristianos inteligentes
y debemos reconocerlo.
O Dios es responsable por el tsunami,
o Dios no está en control.
Después de esta tragedia, las historias de supervivencia empezaron a surgir.
Probablemente hayan escuchado algunas de estas.
El hombre que surfeo la ola.
La chica adolescente que reconoció el peligro
porque justo le habían enseñado sobre maremotos en la escuela.
Luego estaba la congregación que justo dejó su iglesia habitual en la costa
para tener el servicio en las colinas.
El predicador dio un sermón extra largo,
así estuvieron fuera de peligro cuando la ola rompio.
Luego alguien dijo que Dios estaba cuidando de ellos.
Entonces la siguiente pregunta es sobre parcialidad.
¿Podemos ganarnos el favor de Dios alabandolo y creyendo en él?
¿Dios demanda nuestra lealtad, como un tirano medieval?
¿Un Dios que cuida de los suyos, así los cristianos estarán bien,
mientras el resto muere?
Un "nosotros y ellos" cósmico, y un Dios que ¿es culpable de la peor clase de favoritismo?
Eso sería terrible,
y ese sería el punto en el que devolvería mi membresía.
Un Dios así sería moralmente inferior a los más altos ideales de la humanidad.
Entonces ¿quién es Dios, si no es el gran titiritero o protector de su tribu?
Tal vez Dios permite que pasen cosas terribles,
para que el heroísmo y la compasión sobresalgan.
Tal vez Dios nos está probando, probando nuetra caridad, nuestra fe.
Tal vez haya un gran plan cósmico que permite un horrendo sufrimiento
para que todo termine bien al final.
Puede ser, pero estas ideas son todas variaciones de un Dios que controla todo.
El comandante supremo jugando con las unidades desechables en una gran campaña.
Seguimos estando con el Dios que puede hacer el tsunami y permite Auschwitz.
En su gran novela, "Los Hermanos Karamazov", Dostoevsky le da estas palabras a Ivan,
dirigidas a su hermano menor devoto y naïve, Alyosha:
"Si los sufrimientos de niños van para juntar la suma de sufrimientos
que es necesiaria para comprar la verdad,
entonces te digo de antemano que toda la verdad no vale tal precio.
No podemos permitirnos pagar tanto por la admisión.
No es Dios al que yo no acepto.
Yo meramente, muy respetuosamente, le devuelvo su boleto."
O tal vez Dios puso todo el universo en marcha al principio
y luego relegó para siempre el control,
para que los procesos naturales puedan ocurrir, y la evolución siga su curso.
Esto es más aceptable,
pero todavía deja a Dios la ultima responsabilidad moral.
¿Es Dios un espectador frio e insensible?
¿O es un amante sin poder, mirando con compasión infinita
las cosas que es incapaz de controlar o cambiar?
¿Está Dios intimamente involucrado en nuestro sufrimiento,
así tal que el lo siente en su propio Ser?
Si creemos algo así, debemos dejar la idea del titiritero completamente,
dejar la idea del controlador todopoderoso, abandonar los modelos tradicionales.
Debemos pensar nuevamente sobre Dios.
Tal vez Dios no hace ninguna de las cosas.
Tal vez Dios no es un agente asi como nosotros lo somos.
Los primeros religiosos concibieron a Dios como una suerte de persona superhumana,
haciendo cosas en todos lados.
Golpeando a los egipcios, ahogandolos en el Mar Rojo, destruyendo ciudades, enojándose.
Esta gente conocía a Dios por sus actos grandiosos.
¿Pero qué pasa si Dios no actúa? ¿Qué pasa si Dios no hace nada de nada?
¿y qué si Dios está en las cosas?
El alma amorosa del universo.
Una presencia compasiva viviendo, apuntalando y sosteniendo todas las cosas.
¿qué si Dios está en las cosas?
En la red de relaciones y conexiones infinitamente compleja que forman la vida.
En el ciclo natural de vida y muerte,
en la creación y destrucción que debe suceder continuamente.
En el proceso de evolución.
En la increíble intrincación y magnificencia del mundo natural.
En el inconsciente colectivo, el alma de la raza humana.
En ti, en mí; mente, cuerpo y espíritu.
En el tsunami, en las víctimas. En la profundidad de las cosas.
En la presencia y la ausencia. En la simplicidad y la complejidad.
En el cambio, el desarrollo y el crecimiento.
¿Cómo funciona esta internalidad, esta interioridad de Dios?
Es dificil de concebir, y pide por más preguntas.
¿Es Dios sólo otro nombre para el universo,
sin una existencia independiente?
No lo sé.
¿hasta qué punto podemos atribuirle una personalidad a Dios?
Al final, tenemos que decir "No lo sé".
Si supieramos, Dios no sería Dios.
Tener fe en este Dios
sería como confiar en la benevolencia esencial del universo,
y menos en creer un sistema de afirmaciones doctrinarias.
¿No es ironico que los cristianos que afirman creer
en un ser infinito e incognoscible
luego atan a Dios a un sistema cerrado y rígido de doctrinas?
¿Cómo puede practicarse tal fe?
Buscando a Dios dentro nuestro. Cultivando nuestra interioridad.
En silencio, en meditación, en mi espacio interior, en el yo que permanece
cuando dejo de lado mis emociones, ideas y preocupaciones pasajeras.
En la conciencia de la conversación interna.
¿Y cómo viviríamos tal fe? ¿cómo viviría yo tal fe?
Buscando una conexión íntima con tu interioridad.
El tipo de relaciones cuando lo profundo habla a lo profundo.
Si Dios esta en toda la gente, entonces hay un lugar de encuentro
donde mi relación contigo se vuelve un encuentro de tres.
Hay un saludo Indio, que seguramente muchos de ustedes conocerán:
"Namaste", acompañado de una inclinación respetuosa,
que toscamente traducido significa
"Aquello que es Dios en mi saluda a aquello que es Dios en tí".
Namaste.
¿Y cómo puede uno profundizar tal fe?
Buscando la interioridad que está en todas las cosas.
En la música y la poesía, en el mundo natural de la belleza,
y en las cosas pequeñas y ordinarias de la vida,
hay una profunda presencia interior que las hace extraordinarias.
Se necesita un profundo estado de atención y una espera paciente.
Una actitud contemplativa, y una generosidad y apertura
a aquellos cuya experiencia es diferente de la mía.
Cuando me pare para hablar a mi gente sobre Dios y el tsunami,
no tenía respuestas para ofrecerles.
Ningún paquete prolijo de fe, con referencias bíblicas para probarlo.
Sólo dudas y cuestionamientos e incertidumbre.
Tenía algunas sugerencias para hacer --
formas posibles para pensar sobre Dios.
Formas que podrían permitirnos seguir adelante, en un camino nuevo inexplorado
Pero al final lo único que pude decir con seguridad fue "No lo sé"
y esa pudo ser la afirmación religiosa más profunda de todas.
Gracias.